first off we want to thank you for being
a sponsor of the red carpet dreaming
tour really means a lot to us place now
what is it about the tour that made you
want to be a sponsor well my personal
mission in life which aligns with the
goals of our project which will get to
is to help mentor and develop young
people around the world I've taken over
the years some 18 people out of prisons
and mentor them in my company and
they've all turned out great it's just
been a labor of love and so that's why I
wanted to get involved with this event
at our project lends itself to that too
and what is the project that you were
doing we just completed a documentary
about the personal life of dr. Viktor
Frankl from Vienna Austria arguably the
greatest thinker of the 20th century
he's best known probably for his
landmark text book man's search for
meaning and our goal with the film is to
reach young people all over the world
fouls by the thousands to help them just
realize that regardless of their
circumstances whether they be hungry
whether they be homeless whether they be
abused whether they be disabled they can
always discover meaning in life dr.
Frankel survived for concentration camps
during Hitler's reign of tera and lost
his father his mother his pregnant wife
killing his brother and yet he went on
to become the pioneer of meaning in our
documentaries about his life wonderful
now tonight is all about living your
dream are you living your dream at this
time we are living our dream with this
film we just finished it it's exactly
what we wanted to do it align with my
personal goals which is the producer
that's why I took on the project and
we're getting ready to release it to the
world and what does it mean to me to be
able to do that with your life to grab
onto something that you can
well I had to go through a lot of
iterations in my life and I've had some
personal tragedies and lost almost lost
my own meeting at one point because i
lost my grandmother my father my mother
my husband and my best friend in the
span of 10 years and I sort of dropped
off into a depressive state and so I
knew of the insert remaining and I had
met dr. Franco personally in 92 and so
it really you know galvanized if you
will my own desire to move forward with
my own life and when I met his grandson
who is our director it just all the
stars were aligned with perfect it's
wonderful was that so you are actually
living the dream that you want I am
actually living my dream that is so
wonderful thank you so much for coming
by this evening and further your support
thank you Bill